Let's read this paragraph in here about these quote
coronal discharges that you guys are seeing and that
completely stops us. Tell us how this came about and who
talked to you about and what you saw.
We reported it on somebody reported it on one of the earlier
flights that some guy up like that the letter is made for
or some where they just began to make a case of that two things.
Where the VHS radio devices would be 50 yards in from some
place. And the other one where my father was on the
old flight, he said, of course, the implant is one of the
spacecraft. It's nice when they're eyes closed.
They're not only in all of these drives. They say they know
that when they were awake, it's not just the spacecraft
was dark and they thought they were in the spacecraft.
But whoever this guy was, you know, that's a very, really
no phenomenon. You get this guy in front of your eyes on
gamma rays or something. So he said, what do you think?
Would we hold our eyes and face the mood? You know, when we
were orbiting it, because it would be more, you get left
this guy just faces the mood in a way from them.
You know, that's the thing where it's due to the mood or
anywhere. It's very nice happening. And if you keep your eyes
closed, then you're awake down there and it's starting to
think about it. But if you're going to add, you can sit down
and it's more high. It's the size of this drive. You can see
his whole life is really, you know, one eye or the other eye.
Because we want to find it is we have to find it. I guess the
part of the leader is right at the eyeball, or at the
very, very parallel. And we get either a plant like that, or
we get a tree. And I do think I know the way they got a
plant or a tree. And I do think there's a lot of more with my
eyes and my white eyes. But I can tell which eye is
what I was talking to. I'm trying to tell you the reason you
get it, because it's where he's left, but it's always
out of that kind of space. But I've got to quit for the
problem. They should have protected you, they should have all, they
should have picked them all up.
I remember their conversation about it.
I can't remember it was one of the more predominantly
others. But I agree with it, but I don't know if you're not seeing
the pole, but it's not something external to you, there's something
that's in front of you.
Inside of the car here, I'm going to talk to you that's one.
Apparently they know that. They're just complaining,
no, no, no.
Well, we've been looking for cosmic rays, you know, cosmic rays
strikes. And having, having particles, having nuclei that
go through it, you know, we start at clearback and mercury,
taking photographs of the retina, see if you can see his
streaks across the retina and stuff. We never
could find any in there. And so we stopped that up
early in, well, by the end of the
site. You're the eye is, what's the fancy fuel to run your body,
and if it's doing anything, you're never going to see it, but
any of the back of the layer, you're going to see it, it's going to
grab to the right up to the front pole.
Well, probably what it's doing anyway, it's probably hitting just a single
cell, and yeah, that's all it has to do, particularly make this
flesh, you know, you hit a single cell.
I saw a red line, but I was looking at the MBC
a hander, it was a couple of bucks.
And one right right off, I don't know whether it went
here, you know, right there's one on my hander that's about that
that's just, I just got to be looking at that. And I'm just
almost in the wheel, that's right where you just line there,
it's all your eyes, what if they don't want it, but you want to
the yellow line, it doesn't already do it.
You can't believe it at first, because it's not the first night.
And I know that that, hey, I can't believe it,
it's very low, it's from that single one of the
hard eyes, you can't see them, they can't explain them
at the beginning, they can't tell them to make it.
Wake up at night, you can't see them, they can go to your eyes,
they can tell about what it is, it's really really good.
Let me ask you one more question about heart,
oh here, where the land of distribution of these
are, where this thing is apparently horizontal.
Okay, were these, were these things random,
or did they all seem to be in one direction like were they always horizontal,
or were they at random, they could be at any kind of angle?
So the streets that I saw on, or I just want to ask all the horizontal,
I said I'd say that's just the same line.
It seems to me, I had the impression that they were always roughly in the same
place, and mine were horizontal, so hard on all streets were always.
If I knew where I was looking, it always seemed like the hard on all
streets with a little bit above the center.
And it always seemed to me it went from right to left.
And I would like to be, this yard just to go more towards the center,
and it would be just a, it would just light up this point of light,
but it's closer to the end.
Like some I was flashing a light at you.
That's right.
Yeah, it's not too big of a light at you.
Yeah, it went still, you're very small.
Yeah, yeah, it's a, it's a, it's a, it's important.
Is that about the same for both of these?
Is that the same reaction you had dick, and how the way he described it?
What that says is, you know, my relationship was about 30 degrees yards on what they were
coming, I didn't know it was no further light or whatever.
That's pretty helpful.
But about the same, they seem to appear about the same place.
You know, I know, it's not just, but one of the, the horizontal ones that I saw were
generally exposed by the same way, it was generally fine.
I don't know that I can't include it, I can't remember, I just don't remember it,
I have been down on the lower part of the conviction.
Well, I think it was, we think that dick's telling you that it was a guy's open,
and if others think that he centers eye on the light that he is, they're going to tell.
Like to know that the most one down there that's leafed by a bit of a thick black down there in the hole.
And when making every one of those little circles, and I can lay there for it,
if you don't find that way, they work.
I have an hour, and either open up or close them in the way, if you're not there for a while,
I mean, get one.
And then I get there for a while to go to the left side of the right.
I think you want to sort it out.
And if you think that you're out, we die over there.
Now, you know what you do, it's supposed to be just leave it home.
Yeah, it's supposed to be just leave it home.
And there was a comment that,